a speech today delivered by President
Trump a glowing report card he gave on
the state of the US economy's first year
in office
speaking of workers at H and K equipment
in Pennsylvania Trump cited the
immediate effects of his historic tax
cuts and what they did across America
there has never been a better time to
hire in America to invest in America and
to believe in the American Dream than
right now
Americans crossed oceans tamed the
wilderness dug out the Panama Canal and
launched a man onto the face of the Moon
American hands and grit poured the
concrete in our highways and forged the
steel in our skyscrapers Americans do
anything build anything and create
anything as long as we have pride in our
country confidence in our values and
respect for our great American flag
because America doesn't belong to the
Washington powerbrokers it belongs to
you and I think we've taught them that
joining us now with the reaction from
New York is former White House
communications director Anthony
scaramouche E Anthony this speech was
awesome I know you've already written a
piece for USA Today chronicling all
these successes that Trump has had if
any other president and another party
had had such a year of accomplishment
the media would go up be going bananas
70 70 percent approval rating they'd all
be cheering them but Laura it's common
sense and its policy in policies we know
matters and it's great leadership from
the bully pulpit he's encouraging people
that actually don't even like him like
Tim Cook to invest in America because it
makes so much common sense and it's so
commercially sound that's the reason
Laura and in the next segment I'm going
to talk about this group I talked to
today big equipment distributors heavy
equipment distributors across the United
States unbelievable stories but you see
him in those settings Anthony and you
see him with people who are actually
creating something not people who you
know
just like me to talk for a living but
they're actually creating something
Conte there are concrete things they
know what it's like to make a payroll
every day and I like him in those
settings I want to see more of him with
real Americans creating real
opportunities for other Americans don't
you know no question about it and he's
also benefiting from what I call the
spring loading Laura the last
administration was decidedly
anti-business so there was a hoard of
cash that business leaders were saving
because they were so worried about the
government as he's unleashing growth and
he's reducing regulation which I do
write about in tomorrow's USA Today
piece you're gonna see extraordinary
growth over the next three or four
quarters and I think he's going to
surprise people in the midterms and
remember in we were talking about Apple
you said Tim Cook has said really
negative things about the president all
these CEOs who abandoned Trump's
business council remember that Anthony
they said sure oh this is the end of the
Trump agenda these the Business Council
has disbanded when push comes to shove
who's been better better for Apple
obviously Donald Trump requests Barack
Obama and even but people are still
trying to give Obama credit for this I
kid you not
yeah when Apple jobs you know and I hear
and that will last for a little while
longer but by the middle of next year
there'll be nobody to give credit to
other than the president in his
administration but the really good news
lawyers for the American people
watch how consumption starts to improve
now as each American both middle-class
families lower middle class families
have extra disposable income in their
pockets that'll set off the virtuous
circle that we often talk about in the
economic world are you worried that the
markets overheated Anthony everyone's
like it's gonna collapse it's gonna
can't stay this high can't keep going up
up there's gonna be a correction how bad
could that be so over 30 years that I've
been in Wall Street one of the big
metrics that I look at is the price of
the market relative the GDP that's
starting to trend a little high we're in
that like 175 percent zone Laura but the
very very good news is that you're
seeing a big increase in corporate
profitability and growth and so next
year's earnings will probably support
current asset prices so at these love
I'm totally okay we'll have to see what
happens over the next couple of months
if it continues to go up you know in
Anthony you mentioned this but a lot of
people don't talk about it is the
repatriation of capital profits back to
the United States Wall Street Journal
did this yesterday 2.5 trillion overseas
311 companies it's now starting to come
back and the feds say they're gonna get
upwards of 350 billion dollars in taxes
just from that repatriation we're not
even talking about how significant that
figure is that's wild
it's amazing what viewers need to know
is that there's a terrific multiplier
effect off of those numbers so as that
money comes back into the economy it can
be used for infrastructure rebuilding
airports rebuilding roads of the
electrical grid there's a whole host of
things that can happen now as a result
of good economic policy awesome I can't
wait to see your piece tomorrow USA
Today I'm gonna post it on Laura
Ingraham comm and beyond and thank you
so much for that business